because you're a fan of knives where's
the interesting guys come from by the
way oh that's more metaphorical
um uh the truth is that in the modern
world a knife is not an efficient weapon
it'll easily be overwhelmed by Firearms
um my fascination with with knives comes
more in the sense that they they convey
a spirit to my students where
a knife
is made of steel and steel begins as ore
in the ground it's
and ugly
unfinished product which
through the enactment of knowledge time
and discipline can be transformed into
beautiful shining steel it can have
something which it begins as something
which has no real function and becomes
one of the most functional and important
Tools in all of human history without
which human civilization could never
have even begun it's what separated
humans and took us from the bottom of
the food chain and began our gradual
rise towards the top of the food chain
so it has immense historical and
cultural value but it has this
metaphorical value in so far as the
martial artist begins as a white belt
like iron ore but over time transforms
into some beautiful shining Steel
which can have immense value
um
in addition there's a sense of of
Maintenance as remarkable as steel is
it is in need of constant maintenance it
will fall apart through rust and neglect
will destroy a blade both in terms of
rust and the edge falling apart and so
just as the martial artist it's not good
enough just to to learn the techniques
you need to maintain them over time
and just as steel as perishable so too
are the skills of martial arts and that
when I give a gift of a knife to a
student these metaphorical elements
start to emerge they see okay I began as
iron ore and I want to become the
finished blade
um
there's another sense in which
a knife is morally neutral
a knife can be used to Save a Life it
can be used to cook a meal
but it can also be used for murder for
the worst possible purposes
um Jiu Jitsu is the same way
Jiu Jitsu can make you a better person
it can make you a worse person Judas was
just a power it's not a particularly
great power but it is a power
and like all power it can be used for
both good and bad it's morally neutral
in itself and it's up to us to make sure
that just as the knife gets used for
good purposes rather than bad so to
legitsu be used for good purposes rather
than bad there's also an element where
the basis of the knife is steel
and historically there's always been a
riddle of Steel which is
steel has the property of both
hardness and suppleness
the harder you make steel
the better it's Edge retention becomes
the longer that edge will stay sharp
this is good but it comes at a price
the harder you make steel the more
brittle it becomes
and now that edge
can be damaged easily
so the solution is to make the steel
softer more malleable that will prevent
breakage of the blade and
chipping of the edge
but when you make the steel softer that
comes at a price and that price is now
the edge loses its uh its its sharpness
very easily
and so
the riddle of Steel is how to
work with these two to the greatest
degree possible and create an edge which
is hard enough to stay sharp for long
periods of time but without making the
steel so brittle that the blade overall
is compromised
so too in jujitsu
your task and training is to make the
training competitive enough that you
actually get used to the rigors of of
real Combat
but on the other hand it can't be so
brutal that the athletes get broken down
on the gym to a point where they're no
longer effective
and so this duality of hardness and
softness which we see in the case of
blades is there in the training of the
Jiu Jitsu athlete so I often give a gift
of a knife
to a student when they've done something
significant because it demonstrates in a
metaphorical way these key themes of the
sport
well I've been honored to be
a student of yours I've been plagued by
injury
but I hope to one day earn one such
knife and I think that's a really
powerful metaphor I'm really honored
that you would spend any time with me in
any context but especially on the mat
and especially today in conversation
John you're an incredible person thank
you for everything you do
congratulations
for historic accomplishment it's always
beautiful and inspiring to see greatness
and what what I saw what we saw at ADCC
was greatness rare greatness and it's
beautiful to see that humans can achieve
that kind of thing so thank you for for
making that happen and thank you for
talking today thank you legs